alright looking at what is an explosive  debut did you watch a move yet no have  you done your homework yet I'm a year  lieutenant Star Wars Oh rishikesh is  also silent here all right I guess I'm  the only one who's watching while at  least lots of people in China have  watched it you said 53 million dollars  this is an important movie market second  biggest in the world and you see  Hollywood increasingly focusing on China  because it's where the growth will be  they tailor elements of films to appeal  the Chinese tastes and Star Wars no  different a huge haul here and what it  suggests is that perhaps start where  Star Wars will overtake avatar so we  continue to count the numbers but a lot  of money already spent around the world  on this movie